it looks like it's covered in warts
it's like is it burning
this is gonna be
weird
i'm alexis and i'm the senior food
specialist here at taste state today my
co-workers have challenged me to make a
three-course meal using only one
appliance um do i get to choose what
appliance
oh come on
you can leave it you can leave it
sure
[Music]
i don't drink coffee and i think i've
made coffee
three times in my life i
i don't
i like don't really know how this works
any good chef should be able to cook
with with anything so uh
i'm up for the challenge can i do some
research
okay so apparently cooking with a coffee
maker is a thing so this part is going
to act as like we can boil stuff in here
and then you can use the griddle
griddle but i could use this to try to
get some color on things this is gonna
be
weird
i'm gonna start with the truffles first
since i need to chill for a while so i'm
gonna chop the chocolate uh pretty
finely so that way when i add the hot
heavy cream it's gonna mix really easily
oh i should be heating my heavy cream
right now
reframe
okay so it's seven ounces of chocolate
so i need three and a half ounces of
heavy cream
it seems
like very little
i guess we just heat it up and see how
hot it gets
[Music]
it kind of smells like it's burning
it's fine
the cream doesn't need to be scalding
hot you want it like more than warm to
the touch if you stuck your finger in it
you'd be like ha how long does it take
to make coffee in the morning like 10
minutes more
will it work
ha it might be ready
i hope this is hot
enough it's working
if you were in a hotel room and really
wanted chocolate truffles you could
totally do this
i don't know why you would but who am i
to judge i'm going to chill this and
wash this out
so i'm gonna get the water going for my
shrimp i fear that it's gonna take a
while
all right all right all right uh do i
just pour it in here like pour it into
the big part
so that's why you add the water first
before turning it on this is a real
learning experience here
this is a great idea
i'm going to start prepping
everything for my shrimp
okay the sounds that it's making right
now this is like my childhood this feels
very familiar i feel like this is doing
what it's supposed to
it feels hot so i think i can actually
go ahead and add the shrimp so we just
want to make sure that the shrimp is
cooked through and pink it's actually
turning pink you can see it turning pink
this is amazing
coffee cooking
my confidence level right now i mean i
don't want to get cocky but i feel
pretty optimistic they're actually like
perfectly cooked i actually have to
toast the coconut on the griddle before
i move on you know i feel good about
boiling things poaching things but i
don't know if the griddle is gonna work
so the internet said if i put tin foil
on it it'll act as
like a a pan
this feels i feel skeptical
so i guess i'll just let that get a
little toasty if it does you know i
wanted to do something that i would
actually make at home i feel like i
would serve this at a dinner party or
just make it for myself that's another
reason i feel so excited about this is
i'm actually making food i feel
passionate about oh oh my god it's
actually working it's working it's
working like some you can see some of
the brown bits the coconut got a little
brown and you taste some of the toasted
flavor i'm just gonna make sure this is
good
[Music]
i don't know if i'm allowed to say like
give myself a pat on the back but this
is really good
[Music]
next i'm going to poach the salmon so
i'm just going to heat it up
like i did before in here
it needs to be enough oil to submerge
the salmon
and i'm just going to trim the salmon
down so that it'll actually fit
in the coffee pot i'm going to infuse
the oil with some peppercorns lemon
rinds a bunch of dill
and that'll all heat up together and
infuse
so i had this idea to make these
asparagus ribbons
and i was initially thinking about
blanching them but i think actually i
could steam them in the steamer basket
because the asparagus is so thin
steaming it is gonna work better than
blanching it
stay tuned
i'm getting the oil to about 180 before
i poach i'm gonna add the salmon in
[Music]
this is the weirdest thing i've ever
done
so
i'm gonna keep an eye on this but it
could be done anywhere from like seven
to fifteen minutes so while the salmon
is poaching i'm just gonna roll the
ganache into balls and let them chill
again before i roll them into the cocoa
powder
um
i'm gonna go wash up okay
oh
um this looks
really gross the fat is clearly leaving
the salmon but it looks like oh my god
it looks like it's covered in warts
there's like little balls of fat oh
there's like
oh
okay
oh
okay but look how beautiful that is look
at that cook i'm gonna do a few more
minutes and then wipe off the fat no one
will ever know
while the salmon finishes poaching i'm
gonna roll the truffles in the cocoa
powder i haven't tried these yet but
it's chocolate what can't go too wrong
the salmon
i don't know
i'm gonna go chill these again and then
my salmon should be ready
oh with the dill it's like a sea
creature
oh
yeah we're good perfect i'm gonna blot
this first
this smells a little weird
let me just flake this okay i mean it
looks beautiful
[Music]
it was great you need salt but it's
really nice you can do olive oil poached
salmon in a coffee maker who knew this
needs a thorough wash after
what just happened
on to part two so for this i'm gonna
like
simmer some beans in chicken stock and
thyme just to try to add some more
flavor
i'm just putting beans in a coffee pot
feels wrong
i'm gonna salt them pepper it and let
that
do its thing if i put the asparagus in
the top and then add some more chicken
stock by the time the chicken stock goes
through it might
be done
i don't i don't know this feels
[Music]
oh my god it's like all right it's
already it's done that was so fast
it still has some texture to it it's not
mushy this is perfect i don't want to
speak too soon but it's going this is
going surprisingly well
[Music]
chicken stock's a little rich this is
going surprisingly well
the beans aren't really at a boil
but they're starting to
kind of split
[Music]
it's pretty bland
you know the coconut got toasted had
really nice color
so hopefully these tomatoes can blacken
and kind of get some
[Music]
they can get some color on them
i don't think that's totally gonna
happen but
hopefully they can get some char
oh
okay there's some sound oh
there's a little bit of a little bit of
darken
this is going to be really rustic
my confidence is waning
i wish the beans were cooked more or
like poked as if it was over real heat
but there's nothing else to use this is
as good as it's gonna get this meal
could have been done hours ago this is
not efficient in any way
i'm almost done so i'm gonna text some
friends see if they want to come up and
try and
see if they know that this was all done
with the coffee maker
we do a lot of crazy stuff at tasty so i
feel like they're going to have some
inclination that something's up but
i don't think they would guess a coffee
maker
i get courses here
wine and dined one and done me honey you
did this to me
i did it was a real struggle but i have
prepared a three-course meal nonetheless
course one is a shrimp salad i love chew
with a coffee maker
[Music]
i think it's actually really nice it's
like ceviche yeah it's like ceviche
adjacent
do you like the cook of the shrimp
yeah we're going on to course two we've
got some white beans with olive oil
poached salmon steamed asparagus ribbons
and blistered tomatoes
[Music]
i like it okay
okay
when you left me this morning what did
you think was gonna happen
poor hot water
dinner but this is like a healthy
nutritious meal
i thought you paid good money for one
more thing
third course third course
and then for dessert you get a chocolate
truffle
i know
who are you
and how
very impressive thank you
i can't speak for a minute
i was challenged today
to make all these three courses with a
twist what was it oh god i made all
three courses using only a coffee maker
stop
i could have eaten that meal in a
restaurant
well clearly coffee maker is better for
much more than coffee clearly i'm gonna
share this with the team coffee maker
queen happy makeup queen
[Music]
going into today i was nervous this is
crazy this takes so long but if i was
ever in a pinch if there's the
apocalypse i can make dinner and a
coffee maker i'll be fine
[Music]